PROFESSOR: OK, so
that's our equation.
Three terms-- first term,
spontaneous emission,
second term, stimulated
emission proportional to Nb,
third term increases
Nb's absorption.
Our strategy now is, so
what do you do with this?
This looks like a good
equation, but what are we to do?
We haven't used three, really.
So we can solve for U. And
this time, the equation
won't want to make U equal 0.
It will give us something.
And then we can compare with
a thermal equilibrium relation
to get something.
So that's our goal.
So how do we solve for U?
Let's divide by Nb.
So divide by Nb.
So a 0 here, pass this to
that side, and divide by Nb.
So you get A on the
left-hand side equals--
let's see, should I put the--
well, minus Bba Nb.
Actually, I'll do it like this--
the second term first.
Bab Na over Nb times U--
so I'll put it here,
a U of omega Ba--
minus Bba.
OK, so I moved the first term
to the left-hand side, grouped
the U. Why did I group the U?
Because I said,
let's find what U
is, and try to compare with
other things that we have.
So now we can solve for
the U. U of omega ba
is equal to A divided
by this quantity.
So it's A divided
by a big thing.
Let me factor out the Bab.
So now we have here Na
over Nb minus Bba over Bab,
or A over Bab 1 over
Na over Nb is there,
is e to the beta
h bar omega ba--
It's a minus sign with
respect to number 2--
minus Bba over Bab.
OK, this is great.
We're in very good shape.
In fact, we're here.
Let's compare with
our thermal radiation.
So here is what we got.
And we have to compare
with fact number
three, which is the thermal
radiation formula, which
is h bar over pi squared C
cubed omega cubed 1 over e
to the beta h omega.
And I'm comparing with
the thermal radiation,
U of omega ab.
I canceled the D omegas, because
this is U without the D omegas.
So omega ba minus 1.
All right.
It's perfectly nice and ready.
We need to compare this
formula with this one.
They have to be equal.
Well, this factor, must be
equal to this factor, given
that here you have e to
the beta h bar omega ba.
These are constants.
And the first thing that you
discover is Bba equal Bab.
And so yes, very nice.
This is what we learn
in perturbation theory.
These two processes
have identical rates.
So the first statement
that this equality requires
is that Bab is equal to Bba.
So there's just
one B coefficient,
just like there's
one A coefficient.
And the second thing that
you learn is that A over Bab
is this ratio--
is h bar omega ba cubed
over pi squared C cubed.
So we will be able to
calculate the B coefficients,
because they represent
the familiar properties
of harmonic perturbations
transitions,
and we've done already.
Calculating A is
harder, in principle.
The process of spontaneous
emission is a harder process.
But this relation says that we
don't have to worry about it.
We already, if we know B,
these are constants, we know A.
So many times, even in
problems in the homework,
you will be asked, what is
the spontaneous transition
rate for this decay?
You have an oscillator.
It's in an excited state.
What is the rate of
spontaneous transition?
And then you say, OK,
this is complicated.
But you calculate the
stimulated transition rate,
and then plug in
this coefficient.
So it will not be difficult.
Now, spontaneous emission, as
we discussed there in the top,
doesn't include
the factor having
to do with the density of
photons, the U that tells you
how many photons there are.
Because the photons
play no deep role
in producing the transition.
But at some level,
this transition--
while it's not stimulated by
the photons that are flying
around--
when you calculate it, in a
serious, detailed calculation,
you can think of
them as stimulated
by the vacuum fluctuations
of the electromagnetic field.
So if you were to quantize
the electromagnetic field,
there are vacuum fluctuations.
And those vacuum
fluctuations, you could say,
they are stimulating what we
call "spontaneous emission."
So at the end of the day,
the electromagnetic field
is a quantum field.
And therefore, it has zero
point energies, Casimir effects,
vacuum fluctuations.
You can't get away from it.
So in some sense, everything
is stimulated emission,
stimulated by a lot of
photons or stimulated
by the vacuum fields.
Anyway, we'll still
remain with the name
"spontaneous emission," and
keep those things very distinct.
These rates have
different effects
at different
temperatures, as well.
So we'll consider
that, for example,
in that at low temperatures, the
black body radiation has a very
little number of photons.
So most of the
transitions, if they occur,
are happening due to
spontaneous transitions.
On the other hand, as you
increase the temperature,
the number of photons that
are available per unit volume
increases, and stimulated
emission takes over.
So these are the different
contributions to the rates.
And it gives you a perspective--
at very low temperature,
spontaneous dominates.
At very high temperatures,
stimulated emission dominates.